Alright so it's time for you to try flying solo with NSUserDefaults
by implementing them on this recording app called PickYourPitch.
we can see that the first page allows us to record a sound file.
“Testing testing” And the second page allows us to play back that sound file
as well as adjust the pitch with a slider.
“Testing testing” “Testing testing”
But we can see that when we close the app and restart it the pitch information
that we set is gone.
Test again. Instead of the slider being off to the left where we left it,
it's now back in the middle in its default position. Your challenge is to
make the position of the slider persistent.
Think of it as a simple version of a user preference. If you're making an app
for playing podcast, you might have a settings page where the user sets their
preferred playback speed. And users often expect apps to remember that kind of
preference. So check out the following instructions and see if you can make
this recording a persistent.